so this
is the samsung galaxy note 20 ultra and
this
is the zte axon 30 ultra hey what's up
mkbhd here so you know how you see a lot
of people
like clowning on companies for copying
stuff like as if you should
never copy anything and everything you
always make in a piece of tech always
has to be
totally original this might be a hot
take
but not go ahead copy stuff i'm totally
fine with
companies learning from each other's
successes and downfalls
as long as they copy the good stuff and
on top of all that for my fellow
business majors out there
this is all a perfect example of why the
second mover advantage can be
just as good as maybe even better than
the first mover advantage
in the tech world so case in point this
is the zte axon 30 ultra
now the ultra in the name is probably a
dead giveaway before you even see the
phone
this word gets thrown around a lot in a
lot of the high-end smartphone space but
most popularly by samsung
so zte goes ahead and grabs that name
great but then they went on to put
together
a really compelling phone 10 months
after
the note 20 ultra came out so you can
see the design is pretty nice right and
of course there's only so many ways to
make a glass rectangle look
but they've clearly taken some nice cues
from samsung the front and back
are both gorilla glass 5 and this glass
back has an anti-glare finish that does
a great job of rejecting fingerprints i
really like it
one of my favorite things about the note
series also is that slightly boxier form
factor
you know flatter edges slightly more
squared off design
and it's the same thing here with the
zte you can just stand it right up on
its edge
impressively easily it's got a flat top
and bottom
same power button and volume rocker
placement on the side
and of course the now signature square
camera table
on the back which i'll get to in a
minute zte also curves the display over
the edges
just a little bit i think it's right on
the edge of
starting to get some of those annoying
accidental touches so i'd want it to be
just a little bit flatter but it does a
great job of looking good
for the same reason others have been
doing this for so long the only annoying
part of this build to me is actually the
rails
so samsung does a way better job of
smoothly going from the front glass
to the side rail to the back glass so
when you're holding it
it's just that smooth edge where this
phone
has a pretty big rail bump especially on
the back edge so you could argue maybe
it's a little easier to hold but it just
doesn't
feel as good it doesn't feel as seamless
which i think is a bit less premium
but that camera square that camera
square might be the most identifying
feature of this phone just like it was
with the note 20 ultra and so many other
phones
this time it's a boxy square platform
bump
with this little tab on the side that
says neovision photography
this is branding zte has used in some
other phones in the past
some might find it kind of random and
unnecessary but i think
along with this sort of rainbow finish
on the camera glass
it gives it some personality at least
you know it's not literally cloning
the note 20 ultra it's more of just like
copying the homework but then making a
few changes so that it doesn't look like
it copied the homework you know it is
almost the same layout of cameras as the
samsung but not quite the same
and it is definitely not the same
cameras at all so you're getting
a primary camera an ultra wide a medium
telephoto
and then a periscope telephoto like you
also get
on samsung's ultra but the actual photo
quality from these is
it's okay it's passable i mean i guess
i'm not completely shocked that the
camera isn't as good as the note 20
ultra which is some of the best cameras
on any
phone but it is a little surprising that
this triple 64 megapixel setup
plus a periscope and a camera bump this
big aren't delivering
at least really good photos most of the
time so this this truly is the hardest
thing to copy but it's the biggest
shortcoming of this phone but this is
probably a good time to bring up the
prices of these phones right now
so the note 20 ultra the first mover
still to this day costs 10.99 about 1100
bucks
where the axon 30 ultra brand new
749 and so even though this is
a lower costing phone because it is
brand new i'd actually argue it has
better specs than the first mover right
now it has the newer more capable
snapdragon triple eight chip
the same base storage and a little less
ram but a slightly larger battery and
much faster
65 watt fast charging and up front you
even get a nice little bonus
of an even faster refresh rate display
now this is another perfect example of
that second mover advantage where the
note 20 ultra
at the time that it came out probably
the best display in any phone and i'd
still say it's overall
the nicer display right it's a little
bigger and it gets closer to the edges
and it's brighter
and it has that 1440p resolution zte's
display here
is 1080p at 144 hertz
but guess what when this first mover
came out it could not do
1440p and 120 hertz at the same time so
if you are a fan of high refresh rate
you're using this phone at 1080p already
anyway and so with the newer tech that's
out now you can do
a little smoother 144hz but also you
probably can't tell the difference
between
144 and 120 nevertheless they're both
very smooth this axon 30 is super smooth
and responsive through scrolling
animations and everything throughout the
ui
at this point it's all really about how
the software can take advantage of it
zte's display has a 300hz sampling rate
it's a 10-bit oled that covers 100 of
the p3 color gamut
and it's got a pretty small hole punch
up top it's nice
i like gaming on it i like watching
videos on it it's really nice not
quite as nice as the top of the line
samsung panel
but that costs a lot more so this is a
great display in a 750
phone and even the software here is kind
of interesting
this is android 11 with zte's my os
overlay on top of it and as you've
probably already noticed by now it has
a look to it that includes some very big
colorful
touch targets in the quick settings
something android 12 is picking up very
soon actually
here you can customize which quick
settings show up underneath the huge
ones but the flashlight
bluetooth data and wi-fi will just be
gigantic same with the volume controls
though big
colorful hard to miss and then the rest
of it is pretty basic
not too much bloatware it's nice and
clean when you get the google page to
the left of the home screen if you want
it
i'm a fan but the point is the point is
if you
get a whole bunch of these good things
in one place
then it doesn't really matter where you
get them from
right like even if a bunch of them were
obviously heavily inspired from a
certain other thing
like the square camera bump or the
squared off design
or literally the name of the phone
because
you'll get other things from other
places too the 65 watt fast charging
didn't come from samsung
or even 144 display and then of course
with this phone and every other phone
there's going to be
little things that are new so i got to
give this one credit for a lot of that
software stuff and
especially the big touch targets and
things like that
this software is very well done and also
i am working on a video about
android 12 which will have a lot of
these bigger aesthetics in them so
definitely subscribe if you want to see
that
if you haven't already so that's pretty
much all i wanted to say super quick
video just wanted to
get the thought out there that we should
be
okay with companies especially in tech
they're gonna have to be copying each
other and looking at what else is
happening around them
and as customers we should be okay with
them
looking around learning from each other
as long as they copy
the good stuff so i happen to use the
axon 30 ultra which is pretty new as my
example
i'll leave some full review links below
if you're interested i think it's a
pretty good premium
mid-range priced phone it's not perfect
though definitely does have its
downsides like this phone doesn't have
an official water and dust resistant
ip rating doesn't have wireless charging
it also doesn't work on verizon but
this phone is 750 bucks for a reason and
you get what you pay for but if the
things they have included
are the things you like then well you
might have just found yourself a really
good deal
so yeah it kind of reminds me of that
saying
i think it's a quote that good artists
copy
great artist steal although i might
modify that in this case
where good artists copy great artists
copy but then change it a little to make
it look
not as much of a copy
i think i think that'll be my quote so a
lot of the thoughts
and ideas i get for things i want to
turn into videos definitely come from
stuff i watch and a lot of that is going
to be things i watch on nebula which is
a streaming service
built by independent creators including
myself and that comes bundled with
curiosity stream and nebula is pretty
dope there's a lot of the smartest
creators i know
on there minute physics renee ritchie
tech alter
all using nebula to share their best
stuff and sometimes even trying new
stuff that doesn't quite work on youtube
i've been putting my own videos on
nebula but the ad free versions so you
never see these ads
on nebula so you're welcome for that
shout out in an ad for the ad free
version
but then there's also curiosity stream
which is a subscription streaming
service which has a lot of really well
produced stuff
in my exact subjects of interest so it's
home to thousands of documentaries and
shows about technology and futurism and
inventions
and the social web all this kind of
stuff you can see in the category drop
down on their site
it's pretty amazing there's one called
autonomy which is really good it's all
about us being
on the dawn of completely self-driving
cars
that i've just started it's so good also
they're in 4k
they're ad-free couldn't recommend it
more so since the two together are kind
of a no-brainer you can use my code or
the link below to get both
nebula and curiosity stream bundled in
one
so definitely check it out i feel like
i'm recommending a lot more of that
stuff
in the future either way until the next
one thanks for watching
catch you guys later peace